brothers and sisters helped me on this
new project to sponsor 50 orphans
brothers and sisters inshallah it's 600
pounds a year but i wanted every one of
you guys to get involved by giving even
if it's one pound
please get involved now each other and
help us sponsor 50 orphans for an
entire year
how can we have so many devices with so
many apps which help us monitor our
progress for our body
but none for the soul not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hassana counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
assalamualaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are inshallah
and welcome to this video now brothers
and sisters as you guys know what's
happening in palestine in gaza
where children more than hundreds of
people have been
uh killed maybe over 50 plus or maybe
close to
a hundred children toddlers babies
have been blown into pieces and killed
by an apartheid state
by a terrorist state by a state that's
committing genocide
and ethnic cleansing that's what's
happening now when i was sent this video
i
had to watch this a couple of times
because i didn't get the point i was
like
what's the issue here until i paid
close attention let me see if you guys
are going to catch it maybe sorry from
the thumbnail but listen to it guys
12 people including 61 children have
died in gaza
12 people including two children have
been killed in israel
those figures come from officials i had
to repeat that again so i went backwards
i thought okay hold on a second like
what's the catch here let me hear you
again
12 people including 61 children have
died
guys 12 people including two children in
israel
on a second let's let's pay a little
close attention one last time and i'm
going to repeat after yeah check this
out yeah
so this is let's see what she's saying
for palestine yeah
12 people including 61 children have
died
12 people include including 66 children
i think
six six children have died
have died now let's see how many
uh let's see what's happening with
israeli civilians gaza
12 people including two children have
been killed
12 people including two
have been killed now
the question is why would one use the
word
died for the palestinian children which
are 66
and then used the word killed for two
innocent israeli civilians now you see
guys we're
not only here to take sides two kids
have died
and that is to like that is atrocious
kids are kids b is ready or not
i'm not gonna come and undermine oh it
was just two
even though we can see 66 kids
and hundreds of kids compared to that is
no match however still
they are innocent kids and who's causing
this
israel's causing this why because if you
come at a land
steal the land if you're not see that
someone's going to steal it you come and
kill people bomb children kill them
take their lands build their lands
attack their holy places have an
apartheid state then how do you expect
these people to just be quiet and get
lost you're basically telling them
you are the cause not the hamas rockets
that you created you created hamas by
the way
not their rockets their rookies hamas
didn't exist
before you guys came and did this there
was no hamas so you are responsible for
hamas too
and those kids that are dying is because
of your oppression towards the people
innocent civilians innocent i don't
condemn anyone i don't care if it's
hamas i don't give a damn
yeah if hamas is specifically targeting
civilians
on purpose wrong in islam is haram
but you guys are coming and blowing
people kids into pieces you're killing
them
look at this news anchor look at her
look at her
died let's look at the definitions let's
get the definition here the definition
of died if a person animal or a plant
stopped living he died
of tuberculosis uh be very eager for
something they must be dying for dogs or
something else
or a person animal or stop living
something that stopped living
well let's look at the word killed
caused the death of a person animal or a
thing her
father was killed in a car crash the
cause is the car crash
yeah but even then kilt is someone doing
it
died oh if i said this oh my child died
you're going to be shocked you're going
to be upset if i said my child was
killed you're going to be like what so
do you see
i'm not blaming her it might be that the
fact that bryan sisters it might be the
fact
that she is um she's reading it out
now reading that from who the bbc is
scripting this
why is it for palestinian kids died but
for the israeli civilians killed
you can see how biased they are and
recently they've been putting pressure
on israeli embassy
the ambassador is because of ofcom
complaints
not because they want to and brothers
and sisters we are going to go
and question bbc that's correct assume
we've got some stuff coming up inshallah
and we're going to question bbc
guys in a nutshell and do not forget
they are infiltrating
okay guys so i'm going to end on that
inshallah and you can see how
muslim lives mean nothing so much so
that they will use the terms like died
and for israelis they use the terms like
killed this is
the day we're living in and this is the
day they tell us about human uh
human rights they don't give a damn
about human rights
uh america just gave 700 million plus
uh sales to uh israel for um
uh for weapons so it's very clear guys
this is brave and sisters what's going
on in sha allah we're gonna carry on
obtaining you guys with what's happening
on the ground
share with your friends and family bomb
sisters because i am sensing that they
are shadow banning
my channel and other channels as well